From one Halloween movie with Under-wraps to another one with Halloweentown. But sadly, unlike Under-wraps
This is pretty much exactly what I thought I was gonna get with a cheap lame Disney Channel movie
I guess they made a couple sequels to this, but God help me if I can figure out why. This is stupid!
This is the kind of movie you would see on Mystery Science Theater
It's filled with hokey acting, lame effects, and
surprisingly, not very creative ideas. That is to say, the initial setup is not that bad
Three kids are forbidden to go out on Halloween
Because the mother says they can't. But things start to turn around when their grandmother, played by the late
Debbie Reynolds, literally flies in and says that she needs the mother's help. The kids overhear,
Follow the grandma, and discover that she is in fact a witch and they follow her on this magic bus to Halloweentown
And if you're anything like me you're thinking Halloweentown is gonna be something like Halloweentown the one from Nightmare Before Christmas
Weird buildings, dark, creepy, odd, everything a little askew
But nope! It's a bright cheerful place that just has a bunch of people in Halloween masks. Oh, I mean uh ghouls and goblins, ooh
But Halloween town is in trouble because this evil bad guy who
Kind of looks like a mix between the Grim Reaper, and Jim Carrey's Grinch and acts about as subtle
"Welcome to my museum! AHAHAHAH!!"
Wants Halloweentown to take over the land of the humans
So they don't have to live apart anymore. Actually doesn't sound like that bad of a plan
I'm not sure why they're separate anyway
But nevertheless, the grandma tries to teach the kids how they can be little witches and warlocks to come together and stop his evil magic
Okay, so from a setup like this, obviously story is not gonna be a biggie
This is some excuse to have some really creative images and ideas
And characters and so on and so forth and that's not for the most part what we get here. The writing's not especially
Imaginative it just sort of goes by the numbers. "Hey look, a ghost. Hey look, a werewolf." The acting isn't necessarily awful
But it's just bad enough. Like the 13 year old is supposed to be odd and strange and a bit of a weirdo
"Seeing as how Marnie likes weird stuff so much." "She's got the weird part down pat." "Halloween is like made for her."
Okay
Look and listen to this kid and tell me if you would get that "And how are we supposed to grow up if we can't
explore the world?
Try new stuff and take some risks?" uh-huh No Daria is a weird kid. The Monster Squad are weird kids
You're like the cheerleader from American Beauty trying to be weird
But doing a really bad job at it because you're the everyday average kid
There's nothing odd about you
The brother is the typical geek with all the analysis and book smarts that he brings up at every single moment because that's all he is
"Give me a good nature documentary any day." "Well all that candy causes cavities and gum disease."
"trees are important, too,
you know." "Everyone's got their thermostat set to 68 degrees." Degrees, science
That's my entire character! Never seen that before! And the smallest one is so bad, they only give her a sentence at a time
Hell sometimes just a word at a time "I was pretending."
"I wished the lock would turn into a frog." "The bad thing." the only one who's ever doing a good job is Debbie Reynolds
I don't know what it is. She acted like every single part
She got was the role she always wanted to play. She just puts everything into it
And she's 100% believable even in such a silly idea
"I don't like witches. They're mean and scary" "Oh no no no, sweetheart. I mean they're just like everyone else; some are kind, some are mean. That's
That's the way they use their magic." Aside from that, I'll give some credit to some of the creativity in the make up
I mean don't get me wrong. They're obviously masks. They don't look real, but they're kind of like the Evil Dead movies
You know they're fake, but they're very creatively fake. Some of them have really cool designs, and I specially loved this skeleton taxi driver. "Oh,
first time in town for you kids?" Look at this thing! Look how expressive it is. It would have been so easy just to have a
Skeleton in a cap hat and just have the mouth move up and down
But look at this. The eyebrows have a lot of motion, the mouth is moving left and right as well as up and down
It's actually a really good effect, but then they ruin it with this line: "It's probably an animatronic. Disneyland's full of stuff like that."
What? What are you doing, you dick?! Don't ruin the illusion!
That's like someone coming out to the Muppet Show saying "yeah, you're probably all puppets most likely from the Jim
Henson studio." Little douchebag! Once in a while
there's a joke that gets a little bit of a laugh like I enjoy how the witches microwave has boil and bubble and toil and
So forth. There's a fun little segment where the kids have to get ingredients for a spell like:
hair of a werewolf, Fang of a vampire, and sweat of a ghost. How do they do that in this world? By going to a
Barbershop, a dentist, and a gym, of course! Leading to probably the film's best line: "Ghosts are dead.
Why would they worry about fitness?" but aside from that, it's pretty empty.
I mean just look at this place when I hear Halloweentown,
I want to see something dark and creepy and whimsical, not just any other town with people wearing some masks
It's kind of like a mix between a bad
Goosebumps episode and that really lame Babes in Toyland starring Keanu Reeves. The few creative elements are nice
but it's not enough to cover up the cheapness of both the writing and the budget I
Suppose if you have like little little kids, this is fine. Or I don't know, maybe it did have more of an audience than
I thought they made a ton of sequels, but when you hear "Halloweentown"
And you think of something more like what the cover looks like as opposed to this bright suburban sunny day
Then I say this is a definite pass